I know the left wants us to focus on
that Michael Wolfe book and all its
bombshells those critical pieces of
information that the president chose
down on burgers and he asked for three
TVs in his bedroom
ooh but there's real news to cover and
here it is the Justice Department began
a new investigation into classified
material on Hillary Clinton's private
email server when she was Secretary of
State the FBI launched a new
investigation into whether the Clinton
Foundation ran a paid to play operation
that's a separate investigation and now
senators Grassley and Graham it's a
trifecta just referred christopher's
steel the author of that phony trump
dossier to the Justice Department for
perhaps Criminal Investigation joining
us to discuss those real developments
from Capitol Hill Congressman Jim Jordan
and he's not wearing a jacket you
promised that you were gonna wear a
jacket on the show the next time your
god I'm sorry I'm so buying you a new
blazer Tom buying one for you yeah start
of the new year I should have done that
happy New Year to you I'm just I love
teasing you you know that and of course
of the House Oversight and Judiciary
Committees congressman let's talk about
whether this is a real critical turn for
the Attorney General you know that you
you came out with an op-ed that you
wrote a few days ago we'll get into that
but this is now a new development it's
not fusion GPS this goes right to the
heart of the Clinton corruption the
State Department and at the email server
which of those investigations is more
important in your view they're all
important and they should have happened
a long time ago I think this is a this
is a turning point and I think a lot of
credit goes to chairman noonas and the
push that he's been having and frankly a
bunch of us I mean we've talked about a
senator set or Attorney General Sessions
doing his job over there I think we're
maybe turning a corner here as you point
out getting to the bottom of these
important questions that the American
people want answers to so do you now
take back what you wrote in your
editorial with congressman meadows that
it might be good for Jeff Sessions to
move on given the fact that these leaks
keep
opening in the Muller investigation
we've seen more leaks happen over the
last few weeks critical pieces of
information coming out of that
investigation no there's no there's no
sense that the Trump person leaking that
stuff that's got to be coming out of DOJ
yeah right exactly I think there are
four key things stop the leaks give us
the documents answer our questions I
asked senator congressman attorney
general sessions I asked him in the end
the witness when he was witness in the
Judiciary Committee I asked him I said
look did you pay Christopher steel did
you pay the author of the dossier the
person that senator Grassley and Senator
Graham are talking about today did the
FBI pay him at the same time the Clinton
campaign was paying him and we need a
second special counsel even Lindsey
Graham and a host of members are calling
for that second special counsel to
examine all this so those are the four
key points if there's movement on those
fine that's what I hope happens but if
there's not then there should be a new
attorney general that's what we said in
our piece I like Jeff Sessions I want
him to do his job and if he's going to
do that and as you point out I think we
turned a corner this week on the fact
that they're telling us they're not
going to give us the documents and
access to important witnesses how
significant is Lindsey Graham of course
a former Judge Advocate General a lawyer
for the Jag Corps and Grassley coming
out and asking the Justice Department to
look into the possibility of a criminal
investigation into mists into mr. Steele
who's the one who helped generate and
Shepherd through this fake dossier that
you know could very well have led to the
opening of this entire investigation and
the FISA warrant all the rest exactly
right I want to see what that what they
wrote I want to see what becomes this
but I think it's important the fact that
they're actually wanting to maybe have a
criminal referral for this guy who was
that the author of the dossier who was
being paid by the Clinton campaign it's
reported that he was being reimbursed by
the FBI at the same time we don't know
if that's true but if it is I think
that's problematic certainly so I think
this is this is critical as are a host
of questions I mean think about it well
why did the Justice Department release
some of the text messages why did they
release any at all normally they say
ongoing investigation we're not going to
release any information make any
information public but they gave us
three hundred seventy five of these
Peter struck Lisa and page text messages
wide only 375 where's the other 96%
where's the
the others though the others though
congressman might be related to you know
where they're having a romantic dinner I
mean I guess we don't need to know about
that right there are more at the time
how why do they release any of them and
if so why did they pick the 375 when do
we see the others why did a page leave
the Muller team two weeks before the FBI
knew about the text messages knew what
was contained in these that's
interesting I think so there's a host of
questions I needed to get the answers to
that's what I want to accomplish the
Clinton Foundation spokesperson came out
Nick Merrill communications director
came out and said let's call this what
it is a sham this is a philanthropy that
does life-changing work which
Republicans have tried to turn into a
political football and at the same time
we had Phillipe Ramos who's a former
aide to Hillary Clinton at the State
Department and we had him on last night
and he basically said the same thing he
said Republicans are trying to distract
from their own troubles by gin and up
investigations into old settled matters
you know Laura I wish there was a 1/10
of the intensity to get answers to all
the things we have learned in the last
eight weeks relative to Clinton and how
the investigation was handed and and the
Russian issue 1/10 of the intensity on
all of those as there is on the the
Muller Special Counsel investigation
from the left because to date not one
bit of evidence shows the Trump campaign
coordinated with Russians to influence
the election but we know just as sure as
you and I are talking we know today that
the Clinton campaign paid the law firm
who paid fusion who paid chrissteele who
paid Russians to do what influence the
election and we know that Peter struck
the guy who ran the Clinton
investigation interviewed her
interviewed Mills interviewed Aberdeen
changed the exoneration letter had these
text message with Lisa page where he
said we need an insurance policy to make
sure that we don't run the risk that
Donald Trump gets enacted by the
American people so I just wish one-tenth
of the intensity they have offer for
Special Counsel Muller's investigation
one-tenth of that was applied to getting
the answers to all the questions that
arise from that fact pattern
Adam Schiff congressman Adam Schiff a
lot of people think is leaking
information out of those closed-door
sessions of the committee he says that
you all are blocking his
to bring back witnesses like Don jr. he
wants to bring back and others to get to
the bottom of I guess the potential
obstruction you know what charge against
the president even though what president
really can't be charged you know what
Laura I would be happy they can they can
interview all the witnesses they want
however many times they want whatever
sequence they want if we would just be
able to interview Lisa Paige Peter
struck Bruce or his wife Nellie or Jim
Baker why was Jim Baker the general
counsel at the FBI reassigned just two
weeks ago why did that happen I want to
know the answer to that I want to I want
to get the documents so I can hope I
said I wanted to pose them then I wanted
to pose them and then I want to bring
him on the witness stand under oath
answering questions in front of the
American people it seems like contempt
of Congress as the threat of contempt of
Congress I started to get some balls
rolling over there exactly so that's
good where congressman thank you so much
for joining us and up